[Musique]
smartphone qu'est-ce que tu regardes sur
ton téléphone les réseaux sociaux
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce que tu vas
passer sur les réseaux sociaux
généralement c'est par aqmi à 1000 mais
aussi à des annonces de ce qui se passe
1 pis les ebooks le bien public tu le
dis jamais prend un match et non sur
leur site et tu vas directement sur leur
site rousset ps dont je vois passer
après je suis leur site regardez
généralement c'est les petits accidents
qui se passe
j'aime bien savoir
mais comment tu fais la différence ben
ils soient ils m'ont pas d'image ou
alors c'est pas possible ça se passe
généralement ces mots le monde des
images et c'est vrai que ça peut se
passer
qu'est ce que tu portes du métier de
journaliste moi j'aime bien ce trop
savoir ce qui se passe un peu les autres
pays ici les gens